hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
feeder to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video what we're going to talk
about is how to find the arc length of a
circle using proportions so when you
talk about finding the arc length we're
trying to find out you know the length
of that curve okay if we were to
straighten this arc out right on a
circle okay and what we're going to do
is we're going to use a proportion we're
going to take theta which is the central
angle here divided by 360 equals the arc
length okay which is this length here
divided by the entire circumference so
just to help you understand a little bit
deeper what we're doing is we're making
a proportion because we have the
fraction okay divided by the whole see
if theta is this angle that's the
fraction of the whole circle divided by
360 that's seen you know the entire
number of degrees of the circle equals
the arc length which is the fraction
okay of the entire circumference so
we're doing like the part over the whole
equals the part over the whole right and
then we can go ahead and solve for
what's missing so I'll show you what I
mean in this example let's take a look
so we're trying to find the length of
this arc right here X okay so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do a proportion
we're gonna say 60 degrees okay is to
360 degrees okay so this angle is to the
entire you know circle 360 degrees as
the arc length X is to the entire
circumference a distance all the way
around and the circumference the
formulas 2 PI R so that's 2 pi times the
radius 3 so this can reduce down to 1/6
because 60 goes into 360 six times and
this is going to simplify to 6 pi now
you can cross multiply across the equal
signs so we get 6x equals 6 PI and if we
divide by 6 you can see that x equals PI
inches and that's the length of that arc
so I hope this helps you to understand
how to work with arc lengths finding arc
lengths using proportions subscribe to
the channel check out some of my past
videos and I'll see you in the next
video
you soon